Now another fun love story is you and Kaley Cuoco?
Oh, yeah.
What is going on there?
You guys are roomies. You're co staring together.
(Zosia laughs)
This is the cutest story.
You guys got tattooed.
Tell me....
Blah, blah...
I mean, we always say that our love started with a boop.
I'm actually saved as "Boop" in her phone.
So, the first time we ever met
which very few people believe was our chemistry read
for this show.
And they were like, "Feel free to improv."
And I was like, "Okay, great."
And to this day, I'm like, "Kay, why did you do that?"
She's like, " I don't know, I just had an urge."
And she walked up, and I turned around
and she booed me on the nose.
(audience laughing)
She literally went, "Boop."
And I went, "Oh, I hate it when you do that, don't do that."
And I like smacked her hand away,
and I don't know, we just have said since,
we're like that's the moment that our friendship was born.
It was like, when you fall in love
and we fell in love and now poor Evan has to deal
with me being in love with another.
One of her wrap gifts,
'cause we go to Iceland in season two,
I made her a sweatshirt that says wife in Icelandic.
(everyone laughs)
I love it.
It's a little crazy.
So, she actually surprised me.
We got a tattoo with our costume department after season one
and we walk in
and her cousin's best friend is this amazing tattoo artist,
and she had scheduled for us to get those tattoos.
Well, I think you're a lover
but it seems like everybody loves you really hard back,
which is so amazing and I'm so happy.
What is a life lived without putting it all out there,
and laughing as hard as you can and loving as big.
I know it sounds like a bad mug, you know?
Live, laugh, dance, I don't know, whatever,
but it's like, it's true.
It is true.
I mean, I think it's why it's on mug.
I mean it's why cliches...
It is why it's on a mug.
It's why it's on a mug.
(upbeat music)